political psychologist Dr Jordan
Peterson is one of the world's most
famous and fascinating intellectuals of
books instant sellers tens of millions
watch them online in fact his last
interview on Piers Morgan uncensored so
far been viewed more than 17 million
times and I'm delighted to say that he
joins me again now uh Jordan great to
have you back on the program
well thanks Paris it's good to see you
again I was absolutely astonished
British maybe I shouldn't have been but
by the reaction to our last interview
worldwide the sheer volume of people
that watch the whole interview the way
the clips were disseminated on tick tock
on Facebook on Twitter it was a really
interesting Insight actually into a
whole world that doesn't even involve
actually conventional television anymore
I guess you wouldn't be surprised
because this happens to you a lot but I
was what does it say about
society that that number of questions
well I'm still continually surprised
about it but well I think what it shows
is that there's really no way that
Legacy TV in some real sense can compete
with the absolutely wide open Frontier
of online video distribution where the
cost is low and people can access it
everywhere it's fundamentally the
consequence of a technological
Revolution and there's all sorts of good
things about that and one of those would
be the ability to widely disperse
complex and sophisticated information
which YouTube has been particularly good
at in the long form but it's also
problematic in that it produces all
sorts of alterations and social behavior
that we're only and some of them very
dangerous some many of which were only
just beginning to understand
right Elon Musk has just bought Twitter
and it's creating a huge Ferrari
obviously in many different ways and
he's admitted I'm going to do lots of
things in the next few months and we're
going to get some wrong and we're going
to pull them and try something else he's
going to try and work out a way of
making a sustainable business model but
also he wants to bring back what he
perceives to be genuine free speech on
the platform
um is it possible Jordan do you think
that he can do that or are we now so
entrenched in tribalism particularly on
social media that it's almost impossible
to do what he wants to do
well you couldn't have picked a better
day to talk about this with me because I
just got a paper sent to me today by
Jonathan height he didn't write the
paper it's Paul it would be published
it's published in a journal called
personality and individual differences
and it's an examination of the
personality traits associated with uh
let's say excessive and self-promoting
internet usage and I if you don't mind
I'd like to read you a couple of the
descriptions of what the people found
because it's so absolutely spot on and
relevant I don't think we are descending
into tribalism I think what's happening
is that the virtualization of the world
is enabling
um people who behave in a particular
anti-social way in a self-grandizing and
self-promoting anti-social way and I'll
just read you the descriptions that are
taken directly from this paper so it was
an actual study of online Behavior women
characterized by high self-centered
antagonism neurotic narcissism
Machiavellian views Machiavellian
tactics so that's manipulative
manipulativeness meanness disinhibition
physical sadism and indirect sadism used
Instagram for a longer time and more
frequently than did men in women verbal
sadism and emotionality was is
associated with longer well honesty
humility and conscientiousness was with
a shorter Facebook usage time
furthermore women high in agentic
extroversion so that's manipulative
self-promotion and indirect sadism used
Facebook for a longer time and more
frequently than men
and so I've thought for a while that one
of the things that's happening to us as
we virtualize the world is that we're
enabling us the small percentage of
people it's usually about three percent
in general populations
who used manipulation and reputation
savaging and denigration and
self-promotion so the genuinely
Psychopathic types to dominate the
social conversation and to spew their
poisonous and manipulative Venom into
the public domain not only with no fear
of being stopped and no uh and no
inhibition which is almost all applied
socially but also well-being monetized
and promoted by the people who run the
social media channels and every society
forever has had to contend with a small
percentage of people who will utilize
all the benefits of society only for
themselves they had to contend with the
fact that those people if not brought
under control can demolish the structure
of the entire society and I think the
polarization that we're feeling is a
consequence of their untrammeled
expression online Instagram Facebook and
in and in online comment
um
forums like Twitter and that and so that
that stuff you read out just seemed to
be gender specific to women presumably
also applies in other ways to men as
well on social media oh yeah well I I
think the reason that it applied in this
study in women is because Instagram is
very heavy heavy image use image it it
involves heavy use of images and there
are reasons to assume that because of
that it attracts women who are directed
towards short-term impulsive mating
strategies and that's another sign of
impulsive anti-social and Psychopathic
Behavior I think you'd see the same
thing in man in fact I've been talking
to psychologists great psychologists to
make sure that I'm on the right track
here about uh those who post uh
repeatedly say in online forums
especially in relationship to comments
and you certainly see that same pattern
of sadism machiavellianism psychopathy
and narcissism characterizing The Men
Who who are also incentivized to use
what used to be classic female
anti-social strategies to advance
themselves in the reputational hierarchy
but the bottom line exploiters
fundamentally right but the bottom line
is that there is a small percentage of
people generating a vast amount of noise
what impact is that happening on society
do you think
well I think it it skews our perceptions
of what normal people are like we assume
that what we're getting you know when
you sample the world when you're walking
through it you you make the assumption
that you're getting unbiased an unbiased
representation of the things going on
around you and when you're on a plot an
online platform and say reading comments
you also have the assumption that what
you're seeing is something like a sample
of public opinion but it's not you know
because if if 10 strangers came up to
you randomly in the street then you'd
have a bit of a sample of what people
randomly think but Behavior online isn't
random and the people who post aren't
aren't precisely normal and I have been
talking with Jonathan height and Gene
twangy about this and I think they might
know more about it than anybody else in
the world and it's pretty clear that the
people who are dominating say online
comment sections and I would especially
say this is true of the people who post
anonymously and there's other markers
for for this sort of behavior as well
they dominate the political discourse
and what's happening in some sense is
that we have a new form of pollution
that's also corporate sponsored and it's
pollution of the domain of public
discourse and the pollution occurs
because the social media companies are
either enabling or failing to control
you know those known in the popular
parlance is Trolls but they're not just
comical trolls you know using derision
in some cute way and and having their
say in the Free Speech domain they're
really poisonous individuals and they're
poisoning the entire domain
what can Elon Musk do about it if you
were advising him on this I mean
ironically at the moment you're not on
Twitter a would you do you want to come
back now that musk is in charge do you
think you should be restored
um do you want to be back on Twitter and
secondly what would you advise him to do
about this issue of the trolls and so on
well the first thing I would advise and
I'm going to be advising the political
people I'll be talking to over the next
few weeks of precisely this and I have
talked it over with twangy and height to
make sure that I'm not like I said off
on a personal tangent I would say
there's no excuse for including the
anonymous posters with the real human
beings and I think that social media
platforms who have a certain reach maybe
it's a million subscribers and I don't
really know what figure is appropriate
should be required to implement know
your customer laws and then that the
people who are posting who are genuine
verified human beings willing to abide
by their words with their personal
reputation should be put in one comment
section
and then the online Anonymous cowardly
narcissistic pathological troll demons
who are polluting the public discourse
should be put into different common
section and if you want to go to hell
and visit the troll demons and see what
they have dispute you can but otherwise
you can be among the normal human beings
engaged in normal civil human discourse
and that would separate the bloody
Psychopaths from the from the bulk of
decent normal people and you know 97
percent of people aren't Psychopathic
and so we are talking about a small
minority here but they have the upper
hand see actually there's a percentage
of people who I actually I sorry it's
like I had a psychopath test done on me
actually a lengthy questionnaire and
they concluded I was a good psychopath
and what do they mean by that Excel you
know apparently I wasn't like the
malevolent version it was slightly lost
on me the new one okay well okay look
look it's often the case that people in
the industry that you're in and this
would be true for politics and
journalism as well anything with a
public face are more likely to be
extroverted
and also more likely to be somewhat
disagreeable and those those personality
traits can tilt you towards uh what
would you say a style of callous
exploitation but there are other
personality factors that mediate against
that like conscientiousness and so
people who are hard-working and reliable
for example aren't parasitic in the same
way that the classic psychopath would be
and so it's complicated and it isn't the
case that extroversion and even a
certain degree of disagreeableness in in
and of themselves are dangerous but they
lead like everybody's led to Temptation
in the direction that's in accordance
with their temperament and the fact that
you are a public-facing person and that
you like that would tilt you in one
direction of potential temptation but
that's not necessarily diagnostic now it
is a problem because it probably is the
case that politics and journalism and
entertainment attack attract a
disproportionate number of
machiavellians and Psychopaths because
of the of the status that goes along
with those Enterprises yeah it's not
diagnostic it doesn't mean that if
you're in that industry and you know
you've had a long career and that's also
another marker for failure or for lack
of psychopathy because in nor in the
normal world
Psychopaths exploit and they get a
reputation for doing so quite quickly
and then people avoid them and stop
working with them and so it doesn't work
over the medium to long run as a general
rule
yeah I get it last time we spoke at
length you said afterwards we forgot to
get around to Donald Trump and you were
quite Keen to talk about Donald Trump so
we're going to take a short break and
when we come back I do want to talk
about Trump because the big question
right now in America is is Trump done
children
Donald Trump
what is he is he a narcissist a
sociopath a psychopath
all of those things none of them
I don't think that he's a psychopath
um because
he's been successful in repeated
Enterprises over long periods of time
and he has a variety of people who are
remain intensely loyal to him now he's
definitely extroverted in a very to a
very great degree and he's definitely
disagreeable and so that gives him some
of the traits that are associated with
those personality features but from what
I've been able to understand he's also
very conscientious and hardworking for
example and so that's a real mitigating
factor and so I think it's it's very
easy to demonize someone that you don't
approve of let's say and certainly Trump
has been subject I would say to more
demonization than any political leader
in the west that I can remember in my
entire lifetime including Richard Nixon
and so that's also set him back on his
heels and made him somewhat embattled in
defensive which I don't think did any
great things for
for his personality in some real sense
so I think it's a mistake to assume that
that Trump is a psychopath I think it's
a big mistake I think it's a big mistake
to assume that potent is a psychopath
it's easy to do that but I don't think
the evidence suggests that you don't
want to throw those labels around
casually and you know for if if Trump
was Psychopathic well he did a pretty
good job of keeping the United States
clear of War for four years that's
pretty damn remarkable and he did have a
big hand in promoting the Abraham Peace
Accords and that was pretty remarkable
and those aren't the sorts of things
that you would expect
from the psychopath he also seems to
have a pretty good hand with the working
class so I I don't think it's reason
those are those are reasonable
diagnostic labels too you're sounding
like a you know I can say place on
someone I don't know if it was in your
mouth but you sound like you're you're a
bit of a fan of Donald Trump would you
would you like him to run again would it
be good for America do you think
maybe no I I don't think it would be
good for America would it be good for
him to run that's a diff that's a
difficult question because it might be
that it would be good for America to
have whether or not Donald Trump should
be president sorted out in the public
sphere debated intensely and subject to
an election so it might be very
interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers
um and I say this I hope with due care I
would rather see someone like DeSantis
step forward who shares some of that
forthright
um strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better because the Trump for whatever
virtues he might have and I think he has
the virtues of a Washington Outsider I
think that's quite clear I think that
his his behavior in the political realm
raises the political temperature to a
dangerous degree yeah and uh you know I
say that while trying to give the devil
is due and not casting careless
aspersions on his on his name yeah I
know exactly and I would have said to
somebody else who may well have
presidential Ambitions and has been the
subject of a lot of negativity uh Meghan
Markle Prince Harry's wife who does this
podcast uh Archer well podcaster
archetypes is cool and when she seems to
perennially play the victim the female
victim of all outrages and your name got
dragged into this let's take a listen to
what she said
raise your hand if you've ever been
called crazy or hysterical
or what about nuts insane out of your
mind completely irrational I don't think
that men can control crazy women the use
of these labels has been drilled into us
for movies and TV from friends and
family and even from random strangers
and the fact is no one wants this label
what did you make of that Jordan to be
suddenly appearing on Meghan markle's
podcast as a villain the first thing I'm
calling women crazy
yeah well the first thing I make of it
is that her voice drips with the same
falsehood that the voice of Kamala
Harris drips with it's this
sanctimonious
um full compassionate talking down to
her audience and trying to be sure that
we're all really on the same
compassionate page here and we're all
being victimized by terrible forces that
are arrayed against us and none of
that's really fair and it's it just
grates on me and I do believe uh you you
played a bit of a clip from me when I
was talking to um
um uh Talia
Camille pelia the literary critic and I
do believe that it is the case that it's
very difficult to control female
anti-social Behavior often of the type
that's been pilloried as hysterical and
I think that there is no shortage of
clinical evidence to support precisely
that
um claim it's very difficult for women
to control female anti-social behavior
and females who are anti-social that
feminine pattern is reputation salvaging
under the guise of Compassionate Care
and it's it's extraordinarily
destructive and uh
so I stand by my words
and I do think it scales online because
you can use an anonymous reputation
savaging to unbelievably great effect
online with absolutely no punishment for
your sins so to speak and that is
certainly one of the things that's
contributing to so-called Council
culture and there's no shortage of that
coming from the female side now men can
engage in exactly the same strategies
and they do so online and that's enabled
but um it's definitely see with men and
I've said this before and I do believe
this to be the case the the ever-present
threat of the potential for physical
violence
keeps men from doing that to each other
most of the time in person and that all
disappears online and that means that
those who are prone to do such things to
use corrosive and denigration
denigrating derision for example and
reputation savaging can have a free hand
at it and that includes no shortage of
women and women are often very very
often the targets of that behavior from
their own from their own fellows so to
speak we've talked about
um Trump and Meghan Markle I wanted to
just ask you again about Elon Musk about
what you thought of him as a character
he seems to be a fascinating individual
you know whether he's slightly on the
Spectrum or I'm not sure what his makeup
is psychologically but he's certainly a
creative genius a whirlwind a life force
he's done remarkable things what do you
make of it
well I know people who know him very
well and have worked with him very
closely and these are very solid people
extremely competent and extremely
creative and their admirers of Moscow I
talked with my brother-in-law Jim Keller
who's one of the world's great chip
engineers and he worked very closely
with musk for years and he believes that
in he's in many ways exactly what you'd
think he was he's a genius but he's also
like a a Visionary genius but he's also
someone who's very very good at
implementing very good at running
companies as you can tell because he has
a multitude of impossible successful
companies and so he goes into a company
and he cleans house and puts things in
order and makes things work efficiently
and maybe he can do that with Twitter
um I hope he can because
musk is doing all sorts of things that
appear to be useful and difficult and it
would be a catastrophe to see him
derailed in his efforts and I think he
would you like to be back on Twitter
with Twitter would you like to be back
on Twitter
you know I I was I was I dipped into
Twitter this morning uh when I was
looking at some of the research that I
just shared with you and
um it instantly struck me the same way
it struck me the last time I was on
Twitter it's so it's such a den of
pathology that using it I think is
psychologically damaging and if it's
possible for musk to get the the trolls
and they're not trolls they're
Psychopathic Machiavellian sadistic
narcissists under control then it's
possible that the platform might be
useful I like to share information on I
like to follow people to see what they
were up to a lot of the people that I've
met over the years but man it's a snake
pit it is it is obvious to me that we
know what to do about it before I let
you go John you're wearing a poppy I'm
wearing a poppy we're about to have a
debate after the break about whether
people should be compelled to wear
poppies and I guess this goes to the
wider thing about uh General displays of
I guess signaling your virtue in any way
that you choose should anyone be
compelled to whatever the cause whether
it's a black Square on Instagram when
George Floyd died or a poppy for
Armistice Day or so on should people
ever be compelled
I think that that compulsion especially
in matters of public policy is a sign of
bad policy if you can't get people on
board voluntarily by motivating them
with the proper story then you're a poor
leader and so I certainly certainly
would be opposed to anything
approximating legal compulsion now we
use social compulsion frequently to to
produce consensus let's say and to
enforce it and that's never going to go
away and there's some utility in that
but my general Take On The World Is that
people should be allowed to go to hell
in a hand basket pretty much any way
they choose once they're adults although
they might be encouraged not to do that
and invited not to do that but I'm not a
fan of compulsion for any reason I think
it is a sign of bad policy if you and I
can't play together voluntarily then we
don't have a very good relationship and
it's not going to be efficient and
productive it's going to return Force to
continue and I will take that analysis
to commence our debate uh Dr Jordan
Peterson as always fascinating thank you
very much indeed for joining me
foreign